julia kodesh was a lead on the data
infrastructure team at the covit
tracking project focusing on internal
tooling and data processing in her
parallel life she's a computational
scientist at mount sinai working on
cutting-edge personalized cancer
immunotherapy clinical trials
julia's prior experience includes
leading a team as a data engineer at
oscar and working as a senior software
engineer at google with a focus on data
infrastructure and healthcare-related
initiatives
julia holds a bachelor of science and
master of engineering in computer
science from mit
thanks so much for the intro
hi everyone
i'm julia kodish and i was a data
infrastructure lead
at the kova tracking project uh so today
i'm going to talk a little bit about
this organization
what our goal was a bit of the story
around it and i'll also go into some
technical details about our work
so the kova tracking project was a
largely volunteer organization
we collected state level coven 19 data
and we did this for 365 days uh starting
march 7th 2020 uh through march 7th
2021. um we stopped because uh we
thought that federal data had improved
enough over the course of the year that
we felt confident that we could
that we could do so
so we focused on several categories of
data collection and presentation
our core data set which is what i'm
showing here was testing and outcomes
data so this included cova tests
cases hospitalizations and death counts
so what i'm showing here is a four up
view that we produce every day
we also worked on a covid racial data
tracker which was testing and outcomes
data broken out by race and ethnicity
and this let us show the
disproportionate effect that the
pandemic was having on certain
communities
and then lastly we also track covert
data as related to long-term care
centers
like nursing homes and assisted living
facilities
so each of these efforts was huge
in this presentation i will mainly focus
on the infrastructure behind the testing
and outcomes data
since that's what i focused on at the
organization
so i'll start with a brief description
of our data collection processes uh and
then i'll go into how we stored
and served and ultimately presented the
data to the outside world
so our data collection was ultimately
manual
we got our data directly from state and
u.s territory dashboards uh in the
beginning of the pandemic that was
basically the only place to get it and
the process that we'd settled on as a
group
was collecting data into a large and
structured google sheet which looks
something like this
the data entry team would organize work
in structured shifts and then these
would end in a manual process for
publishing data for that day that would
make it ultimately go live on our
website and our data api
so the important thing to note here is
that every single published data point
was verified by a human being
so i want to start with kind of an
obvious question for a project like this
assuming that we're regularly collecting
data from over 50 websites why not just
scrape and automate the whole thing so
the short answer is change was the only
constant um
unfortunately the data landscape that
the kova tracking project operated in uh
was a pretty substantial lack of
consistency or standards in covet data
reporting especially early on
so
things changed really really often there
were changing dashboards
and to begin with many of these
many dashboards actually kind of seem
designed to obfuscate or at least be
hard to scrape
more generally kind of over time there
were lots of changes to the data formats
that we saw
and also to the metrics that are
actually being reported
and then what's probably the hardest
thing to cache automatically
there could be changes to the meaning of
a reported metric part of the way
through so
even if we'd set up a perfectly
automated system on day one it would be
wrong by day five in myriad ways that
are hard to impossible to notice with
automated checks
so you still come back to human scrutiny
uh being a core part of the process um
ultimately we we decided that we needed
our eyes on data annotations and
contexts at least at some point in the
data pipeline
so this is just one example it's
actually one of the better ones so this
is rhode island's covet data dashboard
from july and september of last year
over the space of those two months you
can see that they changed the dashboard
layout um this is not at all to collap
call out rhode island as a state uh
they're actually great um they provided
a really really good data sheet with all
the data available um but in many other
cases that would look like this this
kind of formatting change would also
come with a change in the data export um
assuming that a that estate website even
supported data exports which was often a
very big if
so data collection had to be manual so
that we could trust our data which was
the most important thing but we ended up
building uh increasingly strong crutches
around our data collection process over
time so one system that i want to
mention here is
we created a website screenshot
framework um you can kind of think of it
as a very domain specific wayback
machine
where we would take automated regular
snapshots of state covet 19 data sites
we did this for a bunch of reasons
firstly data provenance uh it was very
very important to us to be able to show
our work uh where the data came from
which is very closely connected to data
quality um so we needed to be able to go
to go back and check our numbers against
what had been published by the states on
specific dates and answer questions like
how many cases did let's say new
hampshire report on march 30th
and also how do they show that data
which gets us into data annotations
states would make changes to data
definitions
on the regular and this kind of context
had a good chance of being reflected
maybe only in a visual version of the
website as opposed to something like a
data csv or metadata
um in addition to that screenshots also
helped us maintain history uh so this
was particularly useful for
situations where we needed to update our
data um in response to retroactive state
data revisions which happened all the
time um and having older screenshots uh
helped us keep track of what the states
themselves were putting out
and then lastly we did this for archival
reasons so eventually we want to be able
to present a record
of what was reported and when and to
have that record be as complete as
possible
so this is a quick tech overview of the
system that we made
which captures state websites and does a
little bit of sneaky scripting to
navigate to the right data points
uh so in a nutshell we had a python
script
which ran as a crown job several times a
day
to collect screenshots um
i first ran on a personal laptop
and then at some point we decided that
we needed to be grown-ups uh and moved
it to an amazon ec2 instance um so the
script used a cloud service called
phantom.js cloud uh to render websites
and capture screenshots um and also it
let us
phantom gs cloud supported various
custom javascripts to navigate around
before taking a snapshot more on that in
a second
so all these customizations
ultimately lived in yammo configs on
github in general we were a very
github-centered org all of our code is
actually still up on there um
and then ultimately we stored
screenshots on s3 and we made them
accessible on our website um
we found that python lends itself really
well to this kind of thing most of our
code was in python
it's easy to quickly write readable
scripts and there's good library support
also
for things like s3 and and also slack
integration it's not pictured here but
we integrated with slack to alert us to
screenshot failures
so this is an example of a state
screenshot config
it's structured to our use cases so has
a url some web browser settings like
page size
and a message that we use to remind
ourselves uh roughly what this config is
doing and why we needed it in the first
place um the interesting part here is
this bit in the middle called the
overseer script um this example is
definitely not the most complicated
thing we had to do but really often we
would need to do stuff like
click on the fifth tab of this dashboard
which of course doesn't have a reliable
selector name because why would it so
we click on the fifth html element of
this type
then weigh 49.3 seconds for the page to
load click her heels spin around three
times and hope for the best um
a lot of the time this worked uh but
sometimes it didn't
and in cases where it did not one of our
awesome volunteers would take a
screenshot manually and put it into our
screenshot store
so along the way we ended up
basically building an accidental brain
trust of automatically navigating around
arcgis
and power bi dashboards
um i just want to say here this seems an
awful lot like automating data
collection but for the reasons i
mentioned before
where things kept changing
we couldn't fully replace our human
processes
we considered it at multiple points and
decided against it so screenshots were
ultimately a best effort project um
where our competency around uh scraping
power bi
lagged behind our core competency around
coded data collection
at the bottom that's just i'm just
pasting the github repo for our
screenshots
code and customizations um feel free to
poke around any other repos that we have
on there as well
so now i want to talk about data storage
um
as i said the the core tool for data
entry for our volunteers was google
sheets um so let's say now we have all
of this data that we collect very
carefully with our eyes and our hands
uh where does it go
so this part of the talk is
going to involve a lot of our feelings
about google sheets
so a couple more details on our data
entry process
during data entry shifts
lots and lots of volunteers would scour
state and u.s territory dashboards
then everyone would write the findings
into a giant google sheet that i showed
you earlier
which we called worksheet2
no one talks about worksheet one
there's also lots and lots of metadata
attached to every state and everything
is ultimately stored in a bunch of
interconnected sheets
so in general
like many other aspects of the kova
tracking project
work and organization this process very
much had to evolve as we went uh we
you know did a lot of building the plane
uh as we were flying it
because change is the only constant
um
so google sheets is fantastic in many
ways uh it's an awesome tool for
collaborative data entry um especially
for data structured as a table which
ours was
it's generic and flexible enough to
accommodate folks with different
backgrounds and kind of different levels
of tech savvy
and respond to you know different
circumstances like lots of types of data
changes which
came up a lot um and lastly the the
tabular format of our data
was very much baked into our data entry
process and pipelines
excuse me uh every step of the way
so all of that meant that for a long
time google sheets was our world for
anything we needed
and we had pretty awesome tooling within
sheets to make all of these things
possible
this was a mix of google apps script
magic and lots of excel type power usage
and all this powered very kind of domain
specific data collection and published
processes
so using sheets for data entry was
awesome
the problem was that in the beginning we
were also using it as a data store for
time series data which was less awesome
because we started running into a bunch
of issues
so first of all our data just got too
big
we were adding 56 rows
and an increasing number of columns at
least once a day
and because the project ran uh way way
way longer than the few weeks that we
originally thought that we would need to
do this far
this ended up pretty quickly
so the performance of google sheets
started degrading with this much data
and this many people trying to edit it
at the same time
we also ran into issues around
accidentally losing edit history
if the cell got deleted and with a lot
of volunteers this kind of thing is
bound to happen at some point
rolling back mistakes was hard because
all of our tooling was dependencies
coded within the space of sheets
and
problems like this were also getting
harder to prevent within sheets because
as our data got more complex uh so did
the problem of validating it
so we ended up adding a database layer
that took a bunch of the data store and
data validation pressure off of google
sheets
the challenge here was adding a critical
piece of infrastructure in the middle of
a production data pipeline
basically amounted to
building one plane while you're flying
it and then building a second plane
while you're flying it and trying to
hook it up
to the first plane mid-flight with no
interruptions um so those kinds of
changes are never easy but it was worth
it for the separation of concerns
between
data entry and data storage
so some brief a brief overview of our
stack
on the left
we set up a postgres database on amazon
rds and the data in this database became
our published source of truth
we also had an internal api layer
which i'll talk about more in a minute
but ultimately it supported both reads
and writes and it was the only
programmatic route to the database so
this was a python flask gap that was
heavily built on top of sql alchemy
that sat between the database and our
spreadsheets
and this api layer took care of
transforming and validating incoming
data
both from our kind of main data entry
sheet and also other sheets and scripts
that
that we built over time to support the
data editing process um and this
internal api would also transform the
data to feedback out to our website and
our public data api which i'll talk
about a little bit later
then i also wanted to say a couple of
things about the way that we represented
our data um so first of all each metric
was its own data column
it's very straightforward it's easy to
visually scan less error prone to query
that way
and it's also similar to the mental data
model that we kind of collectively built
up over time
so this let us keep the data store
itself
as simple as possible
and then second in order to preserve
history we set it up so the data was
never modified it was only added which i
think is a fairly common approach
but the way that we
would add the data is through batches
so every single data row was attached to
a batch id
um and we could interpret those
chronologically and essentially play it
forward as needed um so this borrows a
little bit from the idea of database
transaction logging
except applied on the data modeling
level
so for example if we had to go back and
revise our data
for some state and some date
in response to a state data revision we
would then know that the newer batch
higher batch id is the data that we
should treat as
currently accurate but since we start
all of it we could also trace these
changes over time
so flask and sql alchemy worked really
well for us here
to let us enforce correctness both on
incoming and outgoing data um
as part of this kind of internal api
layer that did all of the heavy lifting
on data transformation and semantics
so this method our columns are simple uh
our rows are simple and associated with
batches
and then the the last thing that i want
to note here um
we chose to take complexity out of sql
queries in this case um that would have
been another option for enforcing data
and variance um but instead we decided
to keep our sql queries simple and then
move that kind of logic largely into
python
where we could iterate and filter
through
uh all of our data in a way that was
more readable uh less error-prone
and also easier to uni-test our logic
which was pretty important
so overall keeping the data store as
simple as possible was our friend in
this uh and having a model that was a
combination of
simple data representation but then a
layer that would transform it as
necessary for the different use cases
work pretty well um and it's kind of a
more general point uh all of our tech at
ctp ended up being
on one hand generic solutions
on the other hand pretty custom and
scrappy um but on the third hand we
still have things like unit tests and
code reviews so uh from the engineering
standpoint um this was a pretty cool
balance to strike
and on the right here this uh this
became an emblem of our database project
with spreadsheets and data and data
this was a brilliant work by one of our
volunteers
so the last thing that i want to talk
about a little is how we shared and
contextualized the data that we
collected
so i mentioned before that we had a
public-facing data api um this went
through several iterations over the
lifetime of the project
v0 was straight up a public google sheet
that reflected the structure of how we
collected the data
once that stopped scaling which was five
minutes later
we built a v1 of the api which
essentially served out
flat csvs and uh simple json trials
these were basically just key value
pairs for
everest it was testing and outcomes
metrics and then it was all of our data
and then eventually we
fairly laid into the project but we put
out a v2 of the public api which was
structured json files
um so we used what we had learned about
the data over time to organize it a
little bit better so things like nesting
related metrics like grouping all tests
together into a top-level test category
um and then breaking that out further
into like the type of cova test reform
like pcr and antigen and so on and so
forth um it also let us
add things like derived values like
smoothing the data over the last seven
days um
structure the metadata a little bit
better and metadata was a big part of
the project as well
um
so on and so forth uh
so v1 and v2 of this public api
these were effectively a caching layer
on top of our data
that was backed by github static files
so easy to store and serve
scalability was a big concern for us
given that we were eventually fielding
millions of requests per day for this
data
so aside from making the data itself
available um our group tried our best to
use the experience of staring at these
numbers every day
to contextualize the shifting data
definitions and the data itself um
we were not data modelers or
epidemiologists
but distinguishing true anomalies from
data artifacts became a really important
part of what we try to communicate
so as an example of something where
context was really important
a state might suddenly receive a large
data dump of positive cases
which would not actually reflect that
day's data
but it would appear as a scary spike on
the time series um
or a state might change uh the
definition of some metric like how
exactly cases were being counted um so
overall the science communication and
editorial components of the cover
tracking project
became really important to us over time
we published daily tweets giving a data
update with context as needed
and a lot of blog posts a lot a lot of
blog posts going into more detail about
the data that we are working with those
are all still up on our website
covertracking.com
so
ctp was a completely incredible effort
to participate in um eventually our data
came to be used by a ton of people and
organizations um recited a lot of papers
and news stories and even some
congressional reports which was
pretty amazing
seeing policy changes as the result of
making this data available was an
incredible thing
um so this was a
really profound learning experience to
be part of this org for me at least i
think for all of us but one of the many
reasons for that is um
as we grew everything had to scale at
once um the number of volunteers and our
processes and our tooling
and all the things um so i i just want
to end with some data related takeaways
that have been helpful kind of for me to
think about and carry forward um so
first it's very very important to stay
connected to the data
um
data without context is meaningless uh
lying with data is very easy
and depending on the the nature of what
you're working with um you
you have to get your hands dirty and
keep them dirty in a sense
to trust what you're putting out into
the world
it's also important to think about data
storage and representation uh as early
as possible in the lifetime of a project
um infrastructure decisions that are
made early on will strongly influence
what happens later
both
in terms of technology and in terms of
process
in our case the early choice of google
sheets had a pretty strong and
persistent impact on our workflow
that sort of thing is tricky to change
later
but also it's important to be flexible
um so in a project like this where
things change all the time
we had to be willing to adapt our
processes and our tooling
which is also related to not automating
things too quickly
automation is a really good goal to have
but it's one where you need to learn as
much as possible about
the space that you're operating in
in order to make sure that you're
automating the right things at the right
time
so very very very importantly um ctp
went from just a handful of folks in the
early days to
over 800 volunteers in data entry data
quality
outreach reporting infrastructure
communication visualization the website
other teams that i'm not even
remembering right now but people donated
uh 20 000 hours of time
just in data entry alone
and i'm
incredibly grateful for the heart and
soul that went into this project
and the ways that people helped each
other out um
by the nature of the work that we were
doing this was a really intense time for
many people um we're watching and
collecting numbers at the same time as
everyone was also living through it
but we didn't want the organization to
be a great place to show up to every day
so people found
a ton of ways to be creative and kind
and funny
like that database emoji that i showed
you earlier
we actually had a really strong emoji
culture at ctp but um
either way this work would not have been
possible without this community i'm
really grateful to have been a part of
it and a giant thank you to all of our
volunteers who made this possible
thank you so much for listening happy to
take any questions you might have
also feel free to reach out to me on
twitter as well
thank you so much julia what an
interesting talk um
i'm watching here the chat for uh
questions any questions if not i have
one this is a joint project that was
rapidly evolving and
how did you govern this project
so you mean like what my personal
connection was no i mean like how do you
govern a project that evolves that
quickly
with that much data involved that much
web scraping
uh
sorry do you mean like how you
uh sorry i'm not actually not sure i
heard your question yeah like how how
often do you meet how do you do this
like who makes decisions i say i see so
uh the i mean honestly the decision
framework on this project was also
something that very much evolved over
time um i think when it was when it was
just a few of us you know everything was
i mean things were happening really
quickly everyone was kind of doing
everything like
um i initially started as just you know
doing data entry on the project too to
kind of get a sense of what we were even
doing
um
eventually uh not even really that
eventually but the project gained a lot
of volunteers really fast and so um we
we ended up
structuring our processes at the same
time as we also started structuring our
teams
and i would say that every team
depending on the function within ctp
had a different cadence for meetings and
how work was structured so um so a team
like data entry which also had the most
volunteers that was you know that was by
far the thing that needed like the
largest number of people in the largest
set of eyes and human time on it um
their work shifts were incredibly
structured and you know people would
sign up for shifts in advance um we
eventually came up with a training
program like we had data checkers we had
double checkers and like that was
structured and at the same time every
day until the shift was over and whereas
on a project like infrastructure
a lot of that was
i mean that that probably looked a
little bit more like uh um you know if a
startup starts remote first and everyone
just sort of figures it out as we go
along uh the cadence of work there uh
you know we didn't have to have shifts
but
we like instituted code reviews we
instituted sort of like the basic
building blocks of how do we all write a
bunch of code together without
everything crashing at the same time um
so so yeah i would say i would say that
varied uh quite a bit between teams
okay and i have to apologize here i just
saw that there are uh one million okay
less than one million a lot of questions
so um so i'm gonna go with uh them in
order of arrival here adam s who
initiated the project in terms of
leadership and authority
so
the project came about because there
were there were two people that had
known each other for a long time
that
both started putting together google
spreadsheets without knowing that each
other was doing it uh and then they
connected about it and found out that
this was a thing they were both tracking
so
alexis madrigal who's a journalist in
the atlantic and uh jeff hammerbacher
who's done a ton of work in the the data
space in general
initially they both started tracking
testing counts so in in early march 2020
no one was counting tests there were
some people that were sort of attempting
to count cases
but uh the extent to which cases meant
nothing in the absence of the context of
how many people we were testing that was
the original impetus um so
that's that's also why the start of
spreadsheets and then you know like i i
happen to know jeff so that's actually
how i got pulled into this project to
start with we'd worked together before
um
so
initially it was
not a lot of people and then i think
over time lots of
coders and data people and really anyone
who was watching this and
felt powerless to do anything
found a thing where there was like
something we could do which was to write
data in a spreadsheet so that was sort
of the genesis of it
okay and uh thank you we have another
question of user who goes by
m-m-c-a-n-e-a-r
uh great presentation thank you very
much for the deep dive how did you
verify that the screenshots were always
of the data you thought you were
capturing over time and this is also the
last question
for today
absolutely um so that that actually
became
as as as i mentioned screenshots were
best effort in part for that reason
because i mean what like what you're
saying is true it's actually pretty hard
to verify that um we ended up building
that into our data entry processes so
every i i i want to say it was weekly
but i'm i'm not sure i'm remembering
that right but i think about once a week
we actually would have a shift of folks
who would go through and just like go
through the state the the kind of state
of our screenshots see which ones were
stale see which ones didn't work see
which ones needed a longer timeout you
know what what have you um
uh there there were ideas that we tried
and did not go for like
um trying to figure out like doing doing
any any sort of ml to figure out if like
let's say today's screenshot differed
dramatically from yesterday's um i think
this this was a thing that was like sort
of half-heartedly attempted and then we
dropped it because the the time
the time trade-off wasn't worth it just
given the structure of the organization
and but yeah that that was another thing
that ended up being
kind of sort of manual
uh thank you so much julia for taking
the time to present to us today and
thanks for being part of pi data global
2021.
thank you